ils viennent crier leur colère jusqu'à
la porte du bureau du maire des agents
territoriaux de belfort et de
l'agglomération sont en grève pour
s'opposer au remplacement de leur comité
des oeuvres sociales par une structure
nationale moins coûteuse avec pour
conséquence la perte de certains de
leurs droits chez eva temps du match
gagné 400 balles je travaille d'ailleurs
tous les jours j'ai aucun avantage à
part la piscine à la matinée gratuite
il nous enlève notre cause il est comité
des oeuvres sociales
mais nous on veut nous enlever cinq
jours de congés la médaille on a pu le
jeu on a pu tchèque il faut la payer si
on veut la voir il va nous enlever nos
ponts il va nous enlever tout ce qu'on a
effectivement 900 personnes ont défilé
dans le centre-ville de belfort dans les
rangs du cortège
plusieurs représentants syndicaux
d'autres structures publiques
une délégation cgt de l'hôpital nord
franche comté est venu apporter son
soutien on a là pour défendre le service
public les droits et puis les droits des
salariés surtout c'est ça qui est
important et il est clair qu'ils n'ont
pas à subir les conséquences d'une crise
sanitaire
il y en a ras-le-bol de ces études qui
disent que les salariés sont des
privilégiés
de son côté le maire compte remplacer le
régime actuel à partir du 1er janvier
ils refusent l'idée que le nouveau
système sera moins avantageux
bien au contraire il coûtait cher il ne
donnait pas beaucoup d'avantagés nous
avons décidé de le remplacer par le
classe qui est un organisme national qui
offre des prestations supérieures pour
l'ensemble des salariés et qui permet
d'économiser 500 mille euros pour la
ville le bras de fer est désormais
engagé entre la municipalité et certains
de ses agents les manifestants ont déjà
prévu de se faire entendre à nouveau
lors du prochain conseil municipal
[Musique]